[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und einen
guten Abend die Fußball-WM im Sport mit
Norbert Lehmann schönen guten Abend und
sie ist auch schon vorher eines unserer
großen Themen dieser Sendung
Rundumschlag am Tag vor der WM FIFA
Präsident Infantino wirft Kritikern des
Turniers in Katar Heuchelei vor
csringen bei der UN-Klimakonferenz für
die Entschädigung ärmerer Länder könnte
es eine Lösung geben
und die Vorbereitungen für das neue
handy-warnsystem laufen Fachleute aber
sind besorgt dass Betrüger gefälschte
Nachrichten schicken könnten
morgen beginnt die Fußball-WM Kritik am
Gastgeber Katha hat der Präsident des
Weltfußballverbandes FIFA jetzt als
Doppelmoral der Europäer und zutiefst
ungerecht bezeichnet in einem fast
einstündigen Monolog wie ist Johnny in
fantino Vorwürfe gegen sich und die
Menschenrechtslage in Katar zurück ist
international kritisierte infantinos
Aussagen Arbeitsmigranten hätten einen
enormen Preis zahlen müssen um sein
flaggschiffturnier zu ermöglichen
Doha am Abend die Party hat begonnen die
größte fifa-fan Zone in Katar ist
offiziell eröffnet
fifa-Chef Gianni Infantino nutzte den
Morgen für eine Stunde der Abrechnung
mit den Medien mit den WM Skeptikern und
Kritikern in Europa statt auf deren
Kritik einzugehen setzte er auf
Gegenfragen und gegen Kritik
dieses moralische Lektionen erteilen das
ist einseitig
das ist nur heuchlerisch wir Europäer
sind es doch die uns für die nächsten
3000 Jahre entschuldigen sollten bevor
wir morallektionen erteilen
einzuweilen theatralischer Monolog das
wirkt einstudiert besonders dann wenn
der fifa-Chef beschwört ich spreche
heute im Namen alle diskriminierten der
Welt weil er selbst als Kind in der
Schule gehänselt wurde
bei den Gastgebern muss seine Rede heute
gut angekommen sein die Vorfreude ist
groß
meine Gefühle ich bin stolz auf mein
Land ein Traum ist wahr geworden
es ist ein wunderschönes Gefühl ich
erlebe es zum ersten Mal hier
viele cataris verteidigen die
Entscheidung in letzter Minute nun doch
keinen Alkohol an den Stadien zu
verkaufen
eine WM der Widersprüche und ein
schwieriger Spagat für das Gastgeberland
Katar des einerseits ein erfolgreiches
turnieröl andererseits in Sachen
Religion nur wenige Kompromisse eingeht
eine WM wie keine zuvor eine die zum
ersten Mal in der arabischen Welt spielt
Katha ein umstrittener Gastgeber was
heißt das für sie werden sie die Spiele
dieser Fußball-WM schauen Roman leskova
hat Menschen in Berlin danach gefragt
Protest gegen die WM heute direkt vor
dem Reichstag extinction Rebellion
kritisiert die Katar Vergabe nur ein
Steinwurf entfernt gähnende Leere wo
sonst hunderttausende feierten bei
Temperaturen um den Gefrierpunkt keine
Fanmeile von Feierstimmung auch in der
Farbe fußballkneipe keine Spur Besitzer
und Stammgäste machen mit bei der
Boykott Katar Initiative statt
gemeinsames gucken gibt es ein
Alternativprogramm Vorträge etwa zum
Thema Menschenrechte wir werden am
Wochenende Fußballspiele besuchen gehen
und Amateurbereich und auch
frauenfußballspiele
und dann werden wir ganz normal das
kneipenprogramm haben ausgelassene
Stimmung dagegen in der Berliner
magnetbar es sind dänische Touristen
kurz vor dem Start in Qatar jubeln sie
ihren Frauen bei der Handball-WM zu hier
wird ab morgen Fußball gezeigt und
gehofft dass die vielen internationalen
Gäste mit teils ganz anderer Perspektive
ins Gespräch kommen
Eindruck bekommen was passiert hier
eigentlich wie ist die Berichterstattung
in Deutschland warum ist das hier so ein
großes Thema die können hier zusammen
auch diskutieren in anderen Kneipen wird
schon gespielt zumindest am Tisch und
natürlich diskutiert noch nie dürften
die Meinungen zum Thema Fußball schauen
so weit auseinander gelegen haben
sportlich Sport und ich guck mal das
sehr wohl an
und ganz vorgeschrieben hatte Fußball
jeglichen ganz verloren bis jetzt nicht
schauen Gruppenphase wenn ich gar nicht
gucken und dann hinten raus muss man
halt gucken längst nicht alle
Fußballkneipen werden die WM
boykottieren viele aber wohl auf
lebhafte Diskussionen hoffen
und wir schauen nach Ägypten dort wird
auf dem Weltklimagipfel noch immer
verhandelt obwohl er schon längst zu
Ende sein sollte speziell hakt es bei
diesen zwei Punkten
die EU will einen Festhalten am 1,5 Grad
Limit bei der Erderwärmung sollte dieses
Ziel aufgeweicht werden drohte sie den
Gipfel scheitern zu lassen bei der
Einrichtung eines finanztopfes mit dem
Klimaschäden bezahlt werden sollen
scheint inzwischen aber eine Lösung
möglich im Kern geht es um die Frage wer
zahlt ein und wem kommt das Geld zugute
auch Sharm el sheikhisha
da kommt ein wütender Mann im Hemd von
gestern da kommt Europas hauptverhandler
am Morgen nach einer durchfahrhandelten
Nacht und der schickt weil er weiß dass
Europa hier gehört wird eine eindeutige
Botschaft an die ganze Konferenz vor
allem an die ägyptische konferenzleitung
wir sind hier als EU um ein gutes
Ergebnis zu verhandeln aber lassen Sie
mich ganz klar sein es ist besser kein
Ergebnis zu haben als ein schlechtes
zu diesem Zeitpunkt Räumen die Ägypter
die Konferenz längst ab Essensstände
Wasserspender Toiletten ganz so als gäbe
es gar nichts mehr zu lösen auch der
Verhandlungsleiter will gar kein Problem
erkennen
zu schließen oder nicht anzuschließen
diese schwarze Peter Spiel ist die ganze
Nacht betrieben worden deshalb steht die
Konferenz mittags kurz vor dem Scheitern
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass wir
keinen kein Papier hier unterzeichnen
können was vom 1,5 Grad Fahrt deutlich
deutlich abweicht was das 1,5 Grad Ziel
hier beerdigen würde am Nachmittag
ändert sich die Lage es gibt neue Texte
darin für alle Seiten etwas das wichtige
Symbol 1,5 Grad auch der heftig
umstrittene Fond für die Entschädigung
von Klimaschäden wir hatten heute Nacht
ein katastrophal schlechten Text jetzt
ist die Abwehrschlacht soweit gelungen
dass es nicht mehr katastrophal ist
sondern dass es durchaus wichtige neue
Impulse dabei mit drinnen gibt und dass
die wesentlichen Impulse des letzten
Klima Gipfels trotz der geopolitische
schwierigen Lage gerettet werden konnten
dabei nun steht bald die alles
entscheidende Sitzung an
das liegt jetzt also einen Vorschlag für
eine Einigung auf dem Tisch weniger sind
das ehrgeizige klimaschutzpläne oder
kleine Schritte
es ist immer so ein bisschen Vorsicht
geboten bei solchen Klimakonferenzen am
Ende nicht zu laut zu jubeln angesichts
der letzten 48 Stunden die wir hier
erlebt haben die Konferenz ist nicht
gescheit hat immerhin dass die Staaten
sich jetzt zum 1,5 Grad Ziel noch mal
bekannt haben zum 1,5 Grad Limit muss
man richtigerweise sagen das hat ein
ganz hohen symbolischen Wert und dass
die Entwicklungsländer jetzt den
vorbekommen um die Klimaschäden
auszugleichen oder ausgeglichen zu
bekommen von den Industrieländern ist
für die Entwicklungsländer ein Erfolg
die Europäer haben sich in dieser Frage
total verzockt erst wollten sie diesen
vorn nicht und als sie ihn wollten haben
sie alles dafür getan die Chinesen
auszuschließen ob das klappt weiß man
erst wenn zu diesem Fond auch alle
Einzelheiten ausformuliert sind dem
Weltklima wäre noch geholfen wenn man
einen Ausstieg aus allen fossilen
Energieträgern beschlossen hätte das hat
man hier nicht geschafft das bleibt beim
schrittweisen Kohleausstieg und das ist
eben die spannende Frage jetzt für die
Zukunft werden sich immer langfristig
noch die Öl und gas-akteure durchsetzen
oder die auf erneuerbare Energien setzen
aber das ist ja so ein bisschen
Zukunftsmusik wir warten erstmal ab wann
diese Plenarsitzung beginnt und wie sie
tatsächlich abläuft und wann der Hammer
hier entscheidet fällt Dankeschön wie
die
wenige Tage vor der Sitzung des
Vermittlungsausschusses streiten
Ampelkoalition und Union weiter über das
Bürgergeld nun hat CDU-Chef März
Zugeständnisse gefordert die Regierung
müsse einen großen Schritt auf die Union
zu gehen sagte märz beim Deutschlandtag
der Jungen Union in Fulda CDU und CSU
wollen etwa mehr Sanktionen bereits
gestern Abend hatte die Junge Union
Johannes Winkel zum neuen Vorsitzenden
gewählt
in mehreren deutschen Städten haben sich
erneut tausende Menschen mit dem
Protesten im Iran solidarisiert wie hier
in Hamburg demonstrierten sie gegen das
mularegime die schweren
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und das
gewaltsame Vorgehen der
Sicherheitskräfte
in Berlin erinnerten die
Demonstrierenden an Iranerinnen und
Iraner die bei dem Protesten ums Leben
kamen mit dem Slogan Frau Leben Freiheit
zogen sie durch die Straßen
[Musik]
es ging um demonstrative Solidarität
heute in Kiew beim Besuch des neuen
britischen Premierministers sonak er
stellte klar dass seine Regierung
unverändert an der Seite der Ukraine
steht mit Waffenlieferungen aber auch
mit Hilfe beim Wiederaufbau der
Infrastruktur wichtig vor allem für die
Menschen in den befreiten Gebieten
Alexandra Vacano berichtet
das ist der beste Tag seit langem sagen
Sie hier in herson als am Morgen wieder
der erste ukrainische Zug aus Kiew
einfährt und 200 Menschen kehren in
ihrer Heimat im Süden zurück wie
Svetlanas Enkelin
auf diesen Moment haben wir acht Monate
lang gewartet sie hat unter der
Besatzung gelebt sie war sehr mutig
Tränen der Freude sie feiern ihren
Triumph über Russland das erste was die
Tochter zum Vater sagt ist ich liebe
dich
ich habe so lange nicht mehr geweint
aber jetzt endlich wo ich meine Tochter
wiedersehe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der Stadt Singen sie die ukrainische
Hymne ihr Hassan befreit seit mehr als
einer Woche jetzt brauchen Sie das
Nötigste wie Wasser Lebensmittel und
auch Kleidung für den Winter
die Helfer haben viel mitgebracht ich
bin schwanger mir werden diese Kleider
sehr helfen
in der Nähe von Hassan Minensuche 30%
des ukrainischen Territoriums sollen
vermiet sein außerdem Spurensuche nach
möglichen Kriegsverbrechen
für Kiew kommt heute Unterstützung aus
London die ukrainische flugabwehrstärken
das will der neue Premier sunek und
verspricht wir sind den ganzen Weg bei
euch
und auch heute wie jeden Tag kampfbilder
aus dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium zur Zeit
konzentrieren sich die Kämpfe auf den
Osten wie in Don jetzt so der
ukrainische Präsident die Idee einer
kriegspause lehnt er ab
zum ukrainekrieg hat sich auch der
Gipfel der asiatische pazifischen
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft in Thailand
geäußert dem Forum gehören neben
westlich orientierten Staaten auch China
und Russland an die große Mehrheit der
teilnehmenden verurteilt den Krieg
allerdings weiß die Abschlusserklärung
auch auf andere Ansichten hin am Rande
des Treffens zeigten sich die USA und
ihre Verbündeten besorgt über die
neuesten Droge werden Nordkoreas das
Staatsfernsehen dort hatte gestern den
Test einer Interkontinentalrakete
gezeigt dabei war auch erstmals die
Tochter von Machthaber Kim jong-
die Flutkatastrophe im Aartal 2021 hat
eines deutlich gemacht das deutsche
Warnsystem für Gefahren muss dringend
verbessert werden
ein erster Test ist der bundesweite
warntag am 8 dezember ab 11 Uhr
aktivieren die Behörden eine
probewarnung etwa über
sirenen-apps oder im Radio und Fernsehen
zum ersten Mal im Einsatz das sogenannte
sell broadcast-system es soll eine
Nachricht an Millionen Handys
verschicken die Vorbereitung für den Tag
laufen allerdings verschicken erste
Betrüger bereits gefälschte SMS Sven
Regen
Mobiltelefone sind immer mit einer
Sendeanlage verbunden einer Funkzelle
wird nun für diese eine Funkzelle eine
Warnung ausgelöst wie bei diesem Test in
den USA bekommen alle angemeldeten
Telefone eine Nachricht auch wenn sie
auf Stumm stehen im Unterschied zu den
Apps die wir kennen so Nina cut waren
und wie sie ganzen Katastrophen Apps
heißen muss ich mich hier irgendwo
anmelden und ich brauche auch keine App
wenn ich mit meinem Gerät in einem
Funkmast angemeldet bin und das bin ich
sonst hätte ich kein Netz dann bekomme
ich auch diese Nachricht Nina und
katwarn wird es weiterhin geben sie
haben den Vorteil des neben der Warnung
auch viele weitere Informationen
abrufbar sind bei der Apps warnten diese
Woche vor dem großflächigen Ausfall der
Notrufnummern und Teilen des
Mobilfunknetzes dabei wurde aber auch
ein Schwachpunkt deutlich kein Netz
keine Warnung solche Störungen können
natürlich immer auftreten und wenn
Basisstation witterungsbedingt
ereignisbedingt ausfallen erreiche
entsprechend weniger Menschen zurzeit
schicken die Mobilfunkanbieter und
Smartphone-Hersteller Update
Benachrichtigungen um den Empfang der
Cell broadcast Warnungen möglich zu
machen da heißt es genau hinschauen
nicht alle Nachrichten sind echt und
wenn da da Links drin sind wo ich
irgendwo klicken soll oder wenn da
Bilder drin sind dann stimmt vielleicht
irgendwas nicht dann lieber ignorieren
nicht irgendwo draufklicken weil es ist
die perfekte Gelegenheit um Leute per
fishing und Co auf betrügerische Seiten
zu ziehen der warntag am 8 dezember ist
auch ein Test für die alten
handy-generationen manche der älteren
Geräte sind nämlich nur zum Teil oder
gar nicht mehr Update fähig
so und jetzt kommen wir wie versprochen
noch mal zur WM und zur deutschen
Fußballnationalmannschaft Norbert sind
noch vier Tage bis zum ersten Spiel
gegen Japan und da hat heute
Bundestrainer Hansi Flick vom Erholungs
auf den Turniermodus umgestellt mit dem
ersten Mannschaftstraining voll dabei
wieder Thomas Müller und Antonio Rüdiger
nicht dabei dagegen Mittelstürmer Niklas
Füllkrug die Stimmung stimmt die Sonne
scheint die deutsche Mannschaft ist
bester Dinge und auch der virale Infekt
von Niklas Füllkrug scheint nicht
besorgniserregend zu sein es geht ihm
ist nicht so schlecht insofern schaut
man jetzt einfach von Stunde zu Stunde
wie es ihm dann entsprechend geht ich
denke schon dass die Zeit reicht dass er
eben auch
zum Spieltag bereit steht bereit steht
hingegen schon jetzt wieder Thomas
Müller der Rücken zwickt nicht mehr
ich glaube in unserem Alter zwickt
öfters mal aber ich freue mich natürlich
dass der Thomas heute wieder auf dem
Platz zwei Mannschaftstraining neues
gibt es von der FIFA so sollen den
Mannschaften kapitänsbinden mit
verschiedenen Botschaften angeboten
werden sozusagen als Gegenmaßnahme zur
one love-binde von Manuel Neuer
natürlich ist die Kurzfristigkeit schon
überraschend wenn so etwas kommt und das
wirkt natürlich auch so ein bisschen als
ob die FIFA da keine klare Haltung hat
die deutsche Mannschaft will an ihrer
one love-binde auf jeden Fall festhalten
ja und alles rund um die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft später bei uns im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr und
morgen dann ab 15:30 Uhr live im ZDF die
wm-eröffnungsfeier und das erste Spiel
Katar gegen Ecuador
zu den ersten vier achtelfinalpartien
heute im habe ich gesagt zu den ersten
48 doch stimmt ein bisschen Zahlen
durcheinander zu den ersten vier
Achtelfinale Partien heute im DFB-Pokal
der Frauen und da hat Zweitligist
Leipzig für eine dicke Überraschung
gesagt RB schlägt den Tabellenzweiten
der ersten Liga Frankfurt mit zwei zu
eins Essen besiegt Bremen mit 1:0 Jena
den SC sandklar mit 4 zu 2 und Duisburg
unterliegt dem Liga 3 Bayern München mit
0 zu 7
Auftakt der alpinen Skisaison der Frauen
und da hat Lena Dürr ihren ersten
Weltcup Sieg im Slalom nur ganz knapp
verpasst die 31-Jährige kam im
finnischen Levy trotz komfortabler
Führung aus dem ersten Durchgang am Ende
nicht über den vierten Platz hinaus
gewonnen hat die Gesamtweltcup-Siegerin
des Feuers Michaela shiffrin aus den USA
morgen der neue Chance für Lena Dürr
wieder ein Levi und wieder im Slalom
Dankeschön heute gab es den ersten
Schnee in diesem Herbst der auch im
Flachland mal liegen geblieben ist ob es
so winterlich weitergeht das erfahren
Sie gleich von Katja Horner fahren das
heute journal können Sie an diesem Abend
um 23:15 Uhr sehen mit Christian Sievers
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend weiß sind die Wolken rosa
der Schnee blau der Regen und violett
der richtig kräftige Regen heute zogen
Schneeschauer von der Ostseeküste weiter
südwärts und mit Regen und Schnee haben
wir es auch in der Nacht zu tun zum
einen hier im Nordosten aber auch in
Süddeutschland und am Alpenrand morgen
über Tag kommt dann vom Besten ein neues
Regenwald heran und bis zum Abend kann
es dann auch in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen etwas schneiden
gefährlich glatt wird es aber heute
Nacht nicht nur dort wo Schnee oder
Schnee Regen fällt sondern auch in
diesem Streifen von der Lausitz bis zum
Niederrhein denn dort sinken die
Temperaturen in den mäßigen des strengen
Frost von minus fünf bis minus 10 Grad
da droht dann Eisglätte deutlich milder
bleibt die nach dem Oberrhein mit fünf
Grad und morgen kommen die Temperaturen
zwischen der Oberpfalz und der Ostsee
kaum aus dem Frost raus da erwarten uns
null bis zwei Grad drei oder vier Grad
werden es an der Nordsee am Detail und
an der Donau und südöstlich davon sind
es fünf bis zehn Grad am freundlichsten
ist es morgen in diesem Streifen von der
Lausitz bis zum Sauerland und in den
nächsten Tagen geht es sehr winterlich
weiter bei Temperaturen am Montag von 1
bis 11 Grad schönes Wochenende